all right everyone welcome to Hannity
and Tony buckle up what is a big week
straight ahead more breaking news from
the Durham report and now even msdnc's
Chief liberal Chucky Todd he is now
calling on the FBI to be held
accountable uh kind of laughable in one
sense also new developments surrounding
Hunter Biden's poverty claims also
breaking news from John Solomon tonight
about Hunter and the IRS and with less
than two years to go until the 2024
election Democrats are once again
shockingly playing the race card this
time they're trying to vilify the entire
Sunshine State of Florida but first
tonight all eyes are on the Biden White
House where Joe is still refusing to
come to terms on a debt ceiling that is
well pretty imminent according to
Democrats the sky is falling the
American economy and the world's economy
is about to collapse and it's all Kevin
McCarthy's fault when in fact it's
anything but Kevin McCarthy's fault so
why didn't Democrats care so deeply
about this issue over a hundred days ago
when speaker McCarthy was all but
begging the White House you know weekly
monthly day after day to sit down and
negotiate this take a look
we have to negotiate over the debt or
hold government is designed to have
compromise the Republicans control the
house Democrats have a small majority in
the Senate and he's the president he is
playing with the financial markets of
America by saying he wouldn't negotiate
that's why I said the president let's be
rational let's be reasonable and let's
sit down and negotiate when we were
together at the prayer breakfast he says
we're going to sit down the next day
told the entire Congress that we're
going to meet at the Democratic Retreat
he told the Democrats that they that we
were planning meetings he's never had
one meeting it's been more than two
months time is ticking he needs to show
leadership and come to the negotiating
table instead of put is in default
now week after week month after month
the White House says Ben Stillwell
stonewalling Kevin McCarthy they
completely ignored him over and over and
over and over again and they refused to
answer the phone and according to
Democrats there would be no negotiations
it was our way or the highway take a
look we will not be be doing any
negotiation over the debt ceiling
look the president's position is simple
Congress needs to take action to prevent
default without hostage taking in the
meantime we need to take the threat of
default off the table we are not going
to negotiate over the debt limit it's
going to be difficult for president
Barton to negotiate with somebody it was
those type of
legislative terrorists on their team
it was their way of the highway here's
the timeline now the facts are
absolutely on Kevin McCarthy's uh time
and by the way these are facts that the
abusively biased corrupt media mob will
never give you now four months ago on
January 13th the White House Press
Secretary proudly announced there would
be no negotiations as you just heard on
January 20th speaker McCarthy reached
out in Earnest to begin these talks well
they refused over and over and over
again in April McCarthy delivered a dire
message warning that the default was
near well that warning also fell on deaf
ears and then on April the 20th with no
other option the House Republicans they
did their job and they passed the limit
save grow act which raised the debt
ceiling and cut spending in a
responsible way simply by returning to
2022 spending levels that's hardly
Draconian and capping growth future
growth to only one percent and the CBO
scored that bill at a very respectable
and very responsible 4.8 trillion
dollars in savings now of course this
came as a shock to most Democrats they
didn't believe that the Republicans
could ever come together they were
betting McCarthy would fail they bet
wrong take a look he will not even say
what he wants to cut and I'll tell you
why
he can't pass a plan with cuts his hard
right will demand the kind of deepest
cuts that his more mainstream
Republicans won't vote for
and meanwhile Schumer never passed any
plan and he was sadly mistaken now a
short time after Republicans passed the
budget Bill the president then well
begrudgingly reached out to McCarthy but
he still refused to negotiate Joe Biden
was missing in action a whopping 97
straight days steadfastly refusing to
negotiate in public the White House was
vilifying Republicans calling them
wackos a stream extreme Mega Republicans
their favorite term Kareem Jean-Pierre
suggesting that the gop's budget bill
would cause climate change destroy the
planet and quote quite literally melt
bones whatever that means now with just
nine days to go until the Democrats
self-imposed the fall deadline of June
the first well Biden is now finally
conducting last-minute negotiations let
us be clear we're not going to default
that's a scare tactic of the left to
look at foxbusiness.com the U.S
government is collecting more than
enough Revenue to cover its stat and
Social Security and Medicare and other
important programs like defense there is
no invisible line on June 1st where the
country quote automatically defaults and
becomes insolvent Democrats to have been
and continue to play politics this has
been an Optics game now for the White
House all along a way to grandstand to
fundraise to vilify Republicans McCarthy
tried to hammer out a deal months ago
and avoid the drama like a responsible
adult in Washington and actually lead
and keep Promises at the same time
Democrats they don't care about good
governance all the federal government
has now become more dysfunctional than
ever under that guy Joe Biden and now
yet another side show the Biden default
crisis of course which is what this will
be Biden well he could have supported
the house budget he still can right now
avoided default that won't happen the
far left bureaucrats calling the shots
at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue will never
sign a bill that's going to cut the
budget that's not going to happen
especially one that eliminates the 87
000 new IRS agents that we don't need we
need agents at the border but not in the
IRS the Democrats are excited about it
so now yet another week another
festering crisis all at the hands of
Biden the Border crisis uh the inflation
crisis the energy crisis all of it
caused by Joe Biden and his radical
policies and the radical left wing of
his party now they are running the
Washington swamp so let's be clear the
Republicans did their job they raised
the debt ceiling they did it responsibly
Joe Biden bet that they wouldn't get
that done Joe Biden did nothing if there
is a default this will be Joe Biden's
default hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else